what's going on here oh
i love that well you're on tape man
there's no secrets okay
yeah why are you whispering joby
tell us about the yeti you saw yeti i
saw yeti come on
oh [ __ ]
cool guy man he ain't gonna [ __ ] get
it all right check this out you can't
make this up
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of hot boxing i'm evan britton
i'm mike tyson mike we've got a [ __ ]
what the icon in here dude [ __ ] joby
this guy
joby o'gwin welcome to the hot box my
brother american mountaineer
wing suit jumper base jumper
[ __ ] adrenaline junkie it's good to
have you here man
it's great to be here thank you what was
the deal with you man what do you want
to do this why are you so deaf defiant
i like that um you know what mike that's
a pretty good way to
to look at it because what i'm doing
every time i do one of these jumps for
example
is you're saving your own life it's like
you're committing suicide and then
saving your life with a parachute
but here's the deal i grew up in a small
town
shreveport louisiana and i always wanted
to do something special and i i started
traveling when i was like 18 years old
and i went to africa and i climbed mount
kilimanjaro
i love that i want to do that that was
the start of everything for me i never
been overseas never went anywhere
and so i met some guys there they
started talking about the seven
summits the seven highest mountains in
the world the one on each continent
that's the tallest and i
i said how many guys you think have done
that
and the guy said i don't know four or
five i'm like in
in the world four or five guys in the
world in the history of the world four
or five guys did that i'm like i'm doing
that
and so by the time i was 26 years old i
had done all seven i was the youngest
person in the world to do it and just a
handful of guys
what are the seven summits so basically
the seven summits break down as
tallest amount in each continent so like
north is mount mckinley in alaska south
america is mount oconcago and argentina
kilimanjaro in africa mount elbrus is in
russia is europe's highest peak
and mount karsten's pyramid is in
indonesia so that's the kind of the
australia eurasia that that area
asia is obviously mount everest and then
the last one that i actually did was
kind of in that order
was mount vinson in antarctica which was
really quite the adventure and was
really a cool way to finish
the seven something listen when you're
climbing the mountain do you see any
animals up there
see i've had that question a bunch of
times
sometimes in some places if you're in
africa you see all kind of stuff up
there all kind of crazy burrs and
everything and little mountain lion
stuff
if you're in antarctica not so much
yeah it's just cold and quiet yeah yeah
there's just nothing out there
everything's just frozen solid
so it kind of varies um but yeah when i
was in russia we saw some big mountain
lions up in the black forest up there
where we were hiking around that was
pretty cool
you know so it just depends on where
you're at so how do you prepare
there's a lot to talk about but i want
to kind of hit it
one step at a time how do you prepare
for
taking on mount everest what's the
preparation
well i have to say the first time i've
done it three times
so the first time i really i was 24
years old i was young man i didn't know
what the hell i was doing i had climbed
a few mountains but i just never been to
asia
never been in the himalayas so i just
figured
i would just run all the time and then i
thought it's not
doing enough for me so my dad worked in
an office building that was like
30 floors like the tallest building in
shreveport
so i put a backpack on at like 40 pounds
of weight
and i just started running up and down
the stairs every now and then i'd mow
over some guy who was going from one
floor to the next like some
law firm dude carried files or something
i'd come down i couldn't stop because i
was you know so heavy and i just blast
through this guy and be like
sorry let me buy you a beer later but
that's what i did
and it made after a while you get carved
out of wood
just just hammering away like that now i
lifted weights and did stuff like that
but i usually stayed pretty lean you
know 175
180 something like that so your cardio
is just through cardio like now
200 so now i'll whittle it down a little
bit when i go this spring
i'll lose weight till i till i get
shredded down to about 190
and then by the time i get to base camp
i'll have lost enough weight to be about
180.
then when i go to the summit hopefully
everything works out that way then
i'll probably be down i'll have lost
like 30 pounds by the end of it it's
like going to space
you actually are actually going to space
you're you're piercing the troposphere
at 29 000 feet on everest you're going
that far
up so wow it's like space jumping so the
only thing that could survive that has a
certain goat or the eagle
huh the birds check this out
when i was up there the first time the
first time i went up there
i saw this i thought man i got the best
view in the world i had a really
beautiful day it was
it was a gorgeous day like really clear
i could see all the other peaks and
everything like you would envision the
view from the top of the planet would be
and then i saw this big raven this big
black raven just
fly right down on top of me and flew
down the southwest
face and i thought that bird has the
best view i want that view
and so that's why i was like i got to
figure out a way to get to the top
and then jump off and fly away just like
that bird did and land safe at the
bottom
which i figured it out that's beautiful
yeah so how did you so then what was
that
that's the wing suits yeah
basically i found wingsuiting
through a random project that i did for
national geographic i was filming
a show where i did all these different
extreme sports car racing bull fighting
bull riding big wall mountain climbing
extreme white water kayaking big
adventure races and one of the things i
did was base jumping so i had to learn
how to base jump usually i had like a
week i had to learn the stuff and i'd
have a coach and they'd show me and then
i put it together and do something big
at the end wow the bass jumping thing
took me a month
but i said what's the biggest base jump
in the world you can make they said the
north face of the iger in switzerland
i'm like
then i'm gonna go there i'll do that
they're like well
nobody's done that you can't do that
that's like takes years i'm like
give me the right trainers and the
resources they gave me three million
dollars
i'm like in one month i'll be jumping
off the iger watch this
in one month i was jumping off the
aggregate three times in one day
oh boom boom boom how did that feel the
first blue
oh bad the balls go in your throat oh
yeah
all the way you feel it right here yeah
all the way up you just
you can't believe it just stand in there
and you're like but
i'm sure you can relate to this when
you're like that when you're a little
scared
that your training comes back to your
mind right
and the education comes in yeah then you
start thinking
okay here's how i'm gonna handle this
you know i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do
this i'm gonna do this
and it works out when you're right and
you train hard
when you train hard it makes a
difference preparation
preparation yes so much of life is about
preparation
even death yeah even that life prepares
you for death
would you say that preparation
because you're i mean you're you're not
a normal dude man
you know what is it that when you were a
kid
was there anything you did like this
that you
brought this focus to this intensity
like what was your childhood like that
prepared you
to be a guy who could absorb great
amounts of information and training
in a very short period of time and go
out and do the expert level
version of that that's a good way to put
it
i i always had a knack for
if i was interested in something if i
really wanted to do it
i would focus very hard on that and i
would
find a way to do it like when people
when i said i'm going to go climb mount
everest people say how are you going to
do that that's really expensive it takes
all this
what money i mean how are you just going
to go over there and do that but i found
a way
what i found was though if you break
things down like if you take mount
everest for example and you break it
down into how did you
break it down you just start picking
like i would look at the mountain and
say man there's no way anybody could get
up there
but then you go okay well maybe if i put
it into sections
i could do that like there was a
mountain
that's the sixth highest mountain in the
world called choyu it's in china
and i wanted to climb it i wanted to
climb it faster than anybody else
and my friend said how are you going to
do that i said well i'm going to climb
it over three days
i'm going to go to the summit then i'm
going to come back down i'm going to
rest for two days
and i'm going to take it in sections and
i'm gonna do it all
in one go in one day in eight hours i'm
gonna get there in eight hours
and people usually take three or four
days to get up there
but i would section it off to the point
where i'd say okay i'm going to take 150
steps and then i'm going to keep
breathing the same way i'm breathing now
i'm not going to try to catch my breath
i'm just going to keep going
so you start sectioning things off i got
up there in eight hours
this is a world record nobody ever
climbed an 8000 meter peak that fast
the last record was eleven and a half
hours so it showed me that
if you break things down and that was in
the middle and that was fast
that was fast that was really fast
so you still breaking it down yeah
if you think about going from seventeen
thousand feet which is already way the
[ __ ] up there how do you
all the way up to twenty seven thousand
feet eight hours we're having a heart
attack
with no oxygen no ropes no sherpa
from help no radio no nothing just
up there and did it but it shows you you
can do big things
if you break it down and then you train
just like that
you did that you break down these
fundamental things
where you can put it all back together
when you really have to step up and do
it
makes a big difference because it gives
you the confidence to know that you can
do it
yeah is breathing a big part of your
training learning how to breathe
mastering your breath
yes it is the thing that people don't
realize is
if you're trying to catch your breath in
the mountains you're never going to do
it
it just doesn't work that way you're
just going to always be trying to catch
your breath so
i came up with a system that works for
me
where i get into a rhythm like when i
would run i'd run
just under a full sprint for miles so
that i could get to the point where
it didn't bother me to have my heart
rate at 200 for extended periods of time
and then i would breathe so when i'd
stopped to rest
my body was resting my legs were resting
a little bit but i would breathe in the
same pace
so that i was never catching my breath i
was just going i was just going then i'd
count out another 100 steps and another
100 steps and i'd stop
another 100 steps and stop and then
break it down into pieces
the whole deal is if you don't stop that
much
then you go real fast but you still have
to be really fit and strong
listen i understand something about
breathing in the human mind and body
because
if i could do this say if i do this a
hundred times
i would feel totally different yeah you
know my whole body
three times you know i know exactly but
i say a hundred
a whole barometer feels so totally
different there's something different
about it i do tons of breathing
yeah stuff something about bleeding i'm
nuts my wife thinks i'm nuts
i'm walking around the house on this
listen i
listen i do this i even go to the
bathroom
yeah incredible oh yeah breathing that
has a lot to do with you taking the [ __ ]
everything else yeah
it works forever yogi's talk about that
[ __ ] yeah oh it's big time
anything yeah just breathing yeah breath
is incredible so that's got to be
because you're not the connection with
that though
well breathing in through the nose
activates
the pre-frontal cortex and all your
executive functioning so
you're in your best you're brought into
your
you're just your highest self you
brought into your highest
mind healing though yeah sometimes when
i'm yeah weights or something yeah
and i do that breathing and it goes up
and i feel my pain good
and it just helps it helps it helps it
helps me if you can harness that
yeah it's like it's a workout yeah but
it works you know it's just i don't know
how but it works
it's the elixir of life man it's piranha
the yogis talk about it is pure energy
right and so you're [ __ ] but you're
not just like
staying at one altitude you're going up
oxygen level's coming down and you're
keeping your breathing
in that mode yeah
it's it's a meditation yeah you're just
in a rhythm and a meditation and
once i could always find that rhythm
then i could just keep going i was lucky
like that
i just was able to focus
in a way i also actually think that
my ability to deal with like the
conditions had a lot to deal with living
in louisiana
yeah like when they when it would get
hot people thought the mountain's always
cold all the time it's like sometimes
you'd be up there and all the
sun is reflecting off it it gets hot
where you're like
taking everything down to a tv yeah
right and it's really hot
most guys they wilt down and i could
keep going like i was used to that hot
humid
weather you know like that was nothing
to me i don't like that
i don't like it louisiana and new
orleans brutal no it's just
brutal it's brutal and i was used to it
so it helped me
yeah for sure you know i wasn't i wasn't
tired
of swamps imagine being up in that
altitude
well then imagine so you you know you
can't breathe it's very difficult
but then you take into account what joby
does
and you focus on your breathing and your
breathing becomes a part of how you live
imagine how powerful and strong your
body would be
like shaking your hand dude you're like
made out of steel
you know what i mean like you don't want
to work out like 10 hours a day
i'm not i'm sure i'm sure but you know
you i was like oh because i was kind of
curious what is a guy's
physique like who [ __ ] hikes mount
everest
you know but you got to be [ __ ]
strong you got to be
powerful yeah you do you know you have
to be ripped out and ready to yeah
to do it on that level for sure like for
sure there's a lot of guys could be
really decently fit to go up there with
support
but if you're up there by yourself like
me with no ropes no sherpa no oxygen
nothing
that was the first time you did it you
did it with nothing
i did it with nothing i was up there all
by myself with just some
guys out there now there's like 100 guys
up there it's like man when i was there
i was the only man on the mountain it
was [ __ ]
i broke the trail usually you would have
ropes like now you'd have multiple ropes
going to the summit from the base to the
summit
whereas when i did it in 99 for the
first time i'm like this little skinny
24 year old history of a summit everest
a guy named edmund hillary mike
he's from new zealand he was from new
zealand and he took one of the sherpas
with him so the two of them got to the
summit the year was it
1954 right that was the first time
well some dudes in their 20s tried
and they died they're still up there
exactly they're still up there guys
oh yeah
you can see the stuff couldn't have the
weather and stuff they were waiting
all the other equipped and stuff oh they
were wearing like leather boots and
stuff
nail boots oh yeah yeah they didn't they
had no chance you've seen some [ __ ]
on the mountain and uh
tell us the story as we've i've heard it
now like three times but i want to hear
it from you of when you went up the
mountain
time by yourself and one of your oxygen
tanks wasn't working
and what went down and how that
what was going on that day i
i it was 2008 and i was up there
for this was the third time i'd been up
there
so i kind of knew what the score was i
thought
basically what happened though i was
trying to do the fastest descent
of everest my goal was to be like less
than 10 hours from the base of the route
to the summit so i took off in the
afternoon friend of mine said hey on the
radio you should go now
all right i'm going now he told me when
you get to the high camp at 26 000 feet
there's some tents then they have my
initials on the tents and you can go
inside and if it's too cold or too windy
you can grab some oxygen bottles and a
mask everything's up there
just take what you need so by the time i
got up there it was dark
the wind was just blasting me just
hammered me and it
it's cold the oxygen doesn't actually
help you breathe any better it's not
like a scuba tank going underwater
it just keeps you warmer like it just
kind of makes you
give you more to not feel so cold makes
your head clear a little bit
so i grabbed some bottles i grabbed two
hooked one up put it on
put the mask on started going up put the
extra one in there
and after about six hours of climbing
i'm up there all by myself
and i start getting cold i'm like man
that oxygen bottle is out
so i change it out when i changed it out
to the regulator
i still was hearing the oxygen leak out
so i knew that the bottle didn't fit the
regulator
so that was my mistake was at the tent i
didn't check that both of them fit
so instead of having like six or seven
hours of oxygen i had like 30 minutes
holy [ __ ] my whole deal was do i go to
the summit
and risk it or do i just go back down
and be safe
well i went to the summit of course and
as i'm taking the
last few steps to the top i start
getting cold again
i'm like damn it i'm out of oxygen
at the tallest point on the planet so i
just started kind of running down
like just making my way down and i ran
into a few dead bodies that i had
conversations with because i was
hallucinating and everything
but eventually i dragged myself to that
high camp and got some more oxygen put
it on
got all the way down but i did get to
the summit in nine and a half hours
still a world record you have to have
tough um psychological fortitude
yeah it was just like keep moving just
keep moving
just keep moving just keep moving i sat
down to a body that was sitting next to
me
and started chatting him up and after a
while i'm like man this guy's dead
for a long time yeah he was just like a
frozen dude with these blue gloves
and i was just sitting there and i'm
like man if i don't get out of here i'm
going to be
you know yeah yeah
that's crazy think about it like
unbelievable
that all have to do with your
willingness to die yeah you
all have what are you willing to risk
yeah yeah i was willing to risk a lot
all the time
for a long time still like i was boxing
i was that was willing to risk a lot
yeah yeah kind of risk it all
to get to the to the biggest
show you know to do the biggest thing
you make what you doing it's strange no
matter what it is you make it
you make it kind of noble a noble cause
yeah yeah i agree it's great very much
yeah you make it a noble cause
jubilee wow your mind could take your
place somebody else man can't even
conceive of it
and say what is the point the importance
of this [ __ ]
what's wrong with this [ __ ] he
wants to climb it not only is he
climbing he's just
it's too easy that he's climbing he's
fast do it as fast now he wants to leap
in and jump
in and fly around he wants to hang out
with the [ __ ] birds
and he wants to hang out with the angels
you know either way he's flying
how do you answer that joby i think he
just did it about as perfect as it can
be
that's right that's what i wanted and
i'm getting it
i'm living my dream in a you know a huge
way
if you said when i was a little kid one
of these days there's going to be a suit
that allows you to fly
if you work really hard you could master
and do those things it's funny that you
said that because i've watched
and i'm just not that kind of guy but
just hanging around here over the years
i've been hanging around here
i i will be in this room this one is
decorated so different now
but it would be you know seats in here
couches and i was sitting here me and
miles and
we just watch and we will watch the suit
people
and this is what i want to talk to you
about that um
normally it was this young lady that was
uh acquainted with a gentleman that was
and he died
but she kept going and you know once she
dated she couldn't date another guy
that's a normal joke she had the only
date guys to do this and she did
quite a couple of guys that died doing
that but she wouldn't know she can't
date a normal guy like us
after dating a guy like that you know
after dating a guy like that
no yeah serious yeah yeah he's right
he's right
i'm not being funny i mean this is true
i'm not laughing because it's funny and
the guy that she she dated her
ex-boyfriend knows the guy that she's
dating now he was like
you can't you can only she's going to be
the guys that do that stuff
it's a small world yeah super small
yeah super small defying death
you know the death defying what what do
you want to call them
whoo they have to have the name whoo
death defying you call yourself
something fine joby
stunt man most i figure that tries to
kind of
cover all the bases different step
most stuff right
most stuntmen um practice what they do
over and over again you don't practice
what you do always only one yeah
there's only one goal
there's no practice you know it's just
you either do it or you don't do it over
again
so with the wing suits
that's the awesomest thing they ever did
it's incredible yeah
it's absolutely incredible so eventually
they're gonna make a suit where
somebody's gonna be able to fly like
superman you watch
oh yeah well guys take off your wing
suit you're only controlled when you're
in the air
uh-huh but imagine when you get on the
ground you're gonna be able to jump off
and do it again from the ground just
jump up and just go start flying without
going over a cliff
i'm sure imagine they'll get there they
will get there it's being like this
yeah no i'm serious i know i know mike
i don't have no outfit i don't know
you're not [ __ ] around well that
thing um the jump
that's um state of the art but when that
stuff comes that stuff is going to be so
in the way all that stuff yeah the state
of the art stuff just jumping up and
taking off
and being oh yeah and [ __ ] in a couple
hours
yeah a couple of days it'd be like iron
man or something
yeah yeah exactly yeah so how do you
prep for that
how do you get into that so you started
base jumping
you did eiger three times one day
i did that for the show which gave me
access to now the base jumping though
was just you jumping off the platform
right parachute right so when i first
did it
off the iger i had a little jumpsuit on
but it wasn't a wingsuit
they don't have no parachute no they
have one at the very end yeah
i know a few guys who've landed wing
suits without using the parachute but
they're not feeling too good about it
right now
but debating things they're still here
uh actually a couple of them are
okay yep surprisingly so they just
caught a tree or this
god bless them it's crazy but stuff
happens like that
weird stuff i i i the first time when i
went on that trip to the switzerland
that was when i saw my first wing suit
there was a guy who was the location
manager who's a really really good
friend of mine now he was a legend andy
west is like
one of the first guys ever to make a
base jump ever like up in yosemite they
were jumping with skydiving rigs and all
this stuff
he had a suit i was like i thought
okay i my first thing was i could make
money from that
like nobody's doing that so i take that
back to los angeles and start showing
guys this stuff they're gonna be like
there's something to this so i thought
well i got to do it now i got to get
good at it so
i bought some suits they were from
france or something i had a bunch of
them
they were like three grand each or
something but i had the sponsorship for
the mountain climbing from oakley and a
couple other companies so i had
enough money to buy equipment rent
helicopters so that's what i did for the
next three years all i did
was jump out of helicopters every day in
switzerland with like two other guys
filming me to figure out how do you film
it then i figured that out
jesus and that was the technical part
like you know if you're good at one
technical thing
you can make money from it you can make
a career out of it that's what i did i
wanted to be the best wingsuit pilot in
the world
and i wanted to dominate the sport and i
wanted to make more money than anybody
else had made from it i wanted to get
all the big shows and the hollywood
stuff i was like i had a plan like
for me it was a business plan it was a
serious plan which i thought
if i look at it like that then maybe
it'll keep me alive
because this is kind of a crazy man's
sport but i wasn't really a crazy man i
just thought
i want to live the ultimate dream based
on flight
mm-hmm you know i first saw people in
that flying suit they must have been
jealous as [ __ ]
oh yeah you know what i mean you said
that flying through the goddamn
the alps oh you're
you're automatically like the coolest
guy in the room when you do that once i
had it mastered and i started pumping
out videos on youtube and
stuff people are like holy [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is these guys doing what the [ __ ]
is this
what the hell yeah they showed you that
trick
and some of them are crazy because some
of these little passes were wow
[Applause]
yeah you're going like 160 miles an hour
jesus once you hit those rocks you're
dead
that's it you're vaporized
um it's not a very forgiving sport
that's for sure listen i've seen people
hit some bad stuff and survive
too you can't believe him and being
survived some of the hits
you know yeah the human body can
withstand a
tremendous amount of pressure
um so you're very
loose man you're very like fun to be
around you're great in conversation
and i wasn't sure how you would be
because of the fact that you're
constantly
you have sort of a constant relationship
with death
does anybody love you have brothers
sisters girlfriends what the [ __ ] is
your story man
uh how could somebody expect to have you
for long
i probably put my parents through a lot
yeah i didn't realize how much i put
them through
until i had my son he's five years old
he lives in italy with his mom hey
i'm dealing with that now i must have
put my family through hell
yeah yeah and my kids are not even worth
nothing like me but i must have put my
family too how far
i know i do when i think about it now
i'm like i feel bad
a little bit but my parents are proud of
me that i made
something when i you know grew up i got
to do what i wanted to do like i was
living my dream and i was successful at
it
and i was staying alive when a lot of
other people didn't
the mountain climbing thing took a lot
of friends from me
in pretty harsh ways brutal um
any baths get him just
no bear accident just like falling off
the mountain yeah
you know falling for a long way and i've
watched guys fall off the mountain and
just get blown apart and stuff and he's
just brutal and doing body recoveries
and here in pakistan and you go
we got to get these guys out of here and
stuff wrapping their bodies up i mean
pretty just harsh through blood all over
the snow and you're dragging these guys
for miles and it's just like
[ __ ] when you go up those mountains you
see tribes and people like
living in those mountains oh yeah
one time i was in pakistan i was trying
to go climb a mountain called batura 2
which was the highest unclimbed mountain
in the world
it's right on the border of afghanistan
so i'm walking through and this guy
comes out in the beard
from this little yurt tent deal he goes
hey
come here holy [ __ ] i'm like i'm all by
myself
i'm just hiking in my partner was
already been over there that was the
italian guy we were going to climb the
mountain
so i hike in for like three days he goes
hey you want some tea i'm like
okay he walks in he goes do you know
where you're at
i said yeah i got the gps everything's
working i'm
i'm going over here he goes i mean
there's a lot of taliban around here i
know
and i was like really he goes yeah big
time
you better watch out just watch out he
said probably you won't see him
you know he said but you're about the
only white guy here you know
in any stretch around i said well what
about you you have problems with the
taliban he goes
no last week we got rid of the taliban
i'm like oh really how'd you do that
he goes well they were trying to come in
and recruit some of the young guys here
in our village and we just went and cut
all their heads off and put them on
little sticks out in front of the house
here
they don't come over here anymore yeah
and i'm thinking i'm walking by myself
for the next two days
and think about man i didn't even care
like at that time i was like 30 or
something i'm 45 now i was just like
whatever
and i was just did that guy speak
english or yeah he spoke perfect english
oh wow
people in pakistan are highly educated
yeah yeah they speak quite a few
languages
yeah they live in hut hindi and farsi
and
english and they live in undeveloped um
homes and stuff and they speak a couple
of languages mm-hmm
wow he's right it's great
listen you go to russia you may run into
a girl speak seven languages
and you say man she ain't listening
she's poor and has no money and you say
to myself how do i get this girl in
america she's going to make me so much
money
you know what the [ __ ] is good she's
poor she speaks seven eight languages
that's crazy yeah it's incredible it's
like normal
yeah that's incredible
so joby um you're getting ready to do
something right now
pretty cool i am that you've attempted
before
we might think it's cool but his parents
don't think it's [ __ ] cool
no they don't true that's true they
don't think it's cool at all
uh no i'm i'm actually
getting a second chance to do something
that i thought was pretty much done
five years ago 2014 i went to everest i
had
an unlimited budget from discovery
channel
we spent more more than most tv shows we
spent over 15 million dollars basically
to make this show and it would have gone
to far over 20 once we turned it on but
the idea was we were going to do a live
show
from the summit where i would jump off
the summit
with a wing suit and fly down and land
at base camp
they had good luck with nick linda doing
the high wire deal over the grand canyon
so my show was the next show and they
poured
tons of resources into it and i was a
big star and that was great
i i had actually just pitched them a
documentary they turned it into the
the more live bigger theater but that
was fine you know whatever they wanted
to do i worked for them at the time i
was trying to do the best job i could
for the company and the people i worked
for
and they were allowing me to live my
dream and i appreciated that so i wanted
them to
understand that i would work really hard
to make it happen
so i did i did everything i could we got
to base camp
had nbc was there doing all the live
transmission
everything turned on it all worked
bouncing off a chinese satellite going
to new york
and it was beamed out to 222 countries
the entire planet basically
biggest live show ever ever
basically and it was all me it was a
pretty amazing place to find yourself
where you're the star of the biggest
this is the biggest thing that's ever
happened
lately on tv and everything and i was
that guy and it was a lot of pressure
but but i took it well and i just took
it as a job i'm just going to do the
best job i can so maybe i can get some
more jobs with these guys have another
show
work with people i worked with were very
very good to work with
top level professional people and i
enjoyed that high level work working
with people like that
so it was like the biggest opportunity
in my life and i knew
financially it would be huge you know i
had a lot of opportunities that would
come out of that and it already come out
of it and the discovery channel deal was
you know great i got to buy a house in
laguna beach you know
it wasn't all bad yeah that's pretty
awesome but basically i was sitting
there in base camp
and big avalanche came down and killed
all of my sherpa team
killed my my team and that was i heard
that and you're about to go on that
um journey with them huh basically a
producer saved my life he just said hey
are you taking the equipment up that
you're gonna use to jump because we
haven't filmed you explaining that out
laying it out i said yeah i'm taking it
up there he said well
maybe if you stay one more day that
saved my life
do you think you owe this to them
yes good question i do yeah i owe it to
him
i do owe it to him i can't help it
i feel that way i live with that every
day i sent those guys to a job
and they died and that's on me
it is i'm all right about it
but if i could do this then it would be
something special
yeah tell me about it and i think people
would appreciate it the story
and that's what i want to do i want to
tell a story if people can be inspired
by it and that's good
do you have children i have a little boy
what's his name
solomon tyler i like that name solomon
solomon alexander ogwen yeah great name
there's a lot to live up to but i think
he will
and he's a sweet sweet boy and a strong
person
how old he'll turn five in may
wow so my goal is to be back by the end
of may
so that i get to see him on his birthday
back from the mountain
god willing love that good job
so you're heading out there heading back
out
yeah i'll be there in april and
hopefully sometime in the middle of may
we'll get up to the summit and
make the jump i've got better equipment
this time so i'm stoked about that
that's good the equipment i use has
actually been enhanced
i would say by a thousand percent makes
it safer easier better for me
so i hope that'll make a big difference
my game plan for it and the project that
i actually want to make is
is different it's not a live show it's
it's a movie it's the movie i wanted to
make
about my journey and my story and
sharing what happened
to these guys and who they were and what
big he wrote
these monks up there in the paul yeah
yeah what they're about
we get blessings when we go over there
we stop in yeah we stop in and we get
the blessings from the monks
in the tangbache monastery there's
another monastery closer
and higher up near ever more near to
everest
we stop there and we get a blessing in
the morning times when they do it
that's awesome yeah yeah special times
special times up there in those high
mountains like that there's no place in
the world
like the himalayas wow dude well once
you do this man you come back
on the podcast you talk talk to us about
it
yeah you tell us how it went i'll break
it down for you
for sure yeah it's amazing brother well
good luck to you in that i mean
i don't know what else to say but you're
you're [ __ ] inspiration i really
wanna i've had a dream since
i was a kid to do kilimanjaro and
everest
oh well why don't you guys just come
with me we'll do a podcast live from
the summit from the summit that would
not be that hard to do
you know i would have to get on the
treadmill a little bit you know people
yes um
it's their life you know my life this is
worth my life they look at this and this
is worth my life
huh yeah yeah this accomplishment is
worth new at risk in my life
it's worth everything yeah yeah
wow man well thank you for being here
you everything what is our life
are we sounding good what is our life no
let's keep going
what is our life it's the
one thing you have that's the most
valuable thing so when you bet it
on something that's it that's all you
got
right how do we live our life i mean how
do we you and i live a little different
than most people
we see it differently how do we protect
ourselves from the fear of dying
yeah because we haven't had that fear of
much
in our life i lost 16 friends in six
weeks one time for wingsu stuff
in six weeks good friends people i knew
well
and loved and i still i was
flying still doing it and then after a
while i'm like
maybe you know yeah
the odds yeah
they catch up
life is um life prepared like we were
discussing life prepares us for death
you know it just prepares us life is
smarter and nature is smarter than we
can ever anticipate
we react off nature without us even
knowing we're reacting
this this isn't without me doing this
why am i doing this what for a reason i
did this but i had them to do this
you don't even know why why am i moving
while i'm talking you know
this is nature it prepares us for
everything but we think that um
we're running the show oh yeah yeah you
think you're in control
until you're not in trouble
moly are you joby are you in a constant
state of just letting go of
any thoughts of future i mean do you
just stay
have to stay in the moment and
trust the training and yeah i'm just
trying to
be here now yeah yeah that's the goal
works pretty good for me
yeah i mean it i read that book by
rondas
yeah many years ago i loved it people
had it's wonderful
and i really thought that that was a
smart way to look at things
especially for somebody like me well
just the idea the guy wrote a book and
his whole idea was a real simple book
but a friend of mine gave it to me you
kind of sit down and read it all at one
time
so about 10 15 minutes you kind of make
your way through it but the whole idea
summed up is
be here now like don't think about what
happened yesterday or in the past
or think about too much about what's in
the future but if you're really
here in the moment then you're living
the best possible life because you're
here you're absorbing everything you're
getting it all
right yeah instead of letting your mind
and your heart and your soul
make you drift over here thinking about
all this other stuff
it keeps you focused on things you
should and can do
yeah but it also makes it where your
life really is
as full yeah as it possibly can be i
struggle with that
i think a lot about the past it's hard
for me
our path is um
our path is just the past is just
what dead generations
that generation living on the brain of
the living you know what i mean
just think about it we gotta we gotta um
revenge ourselves for this we gotta
revenge our race for this
we gotta revenge ourselves for this and
this and we continue fighting battles in
the past
and we can never go forward in the
future you know we always fight those
generations of negative
insults that we received and stuff yeah
i mean black people got this they're
called latino people got their call gay
people got that call
the ltb people they got there everybody
has their call because no why
because they're not won yet we all won
but we're not conscious
one yeah we're not all conscious one yet
we're still trying to separate ourselves
we're still trying to find things that
separate ourselves and we keep coming
back to we're still one we're still
saying that frustrates us
and we dig and we dig and we think we
get frustrated we can't find nothing to
separate us
and we don't want to be a part of this
we don't want to be a part of that but
the reality is we're all of this this is
who we are
and we don't want to look and face who
we are
you know they don't want to say i'm a
great member my daughter's scared my son
is
why is this why is this because that's
what you are
you know we are what we what our
children are what we hide and
um can deceive conceived from people
comes out in our children and they're
that way naturally
you know how could we live a life
trying to hide who we are to have our
secrets
that are trying to live open
there's there's a reason we don't have
eyes on the back of our head
you know we're not meant to look behind
us no way
it's hard sometimes you have to have
faith that's why we need faith
that's the reason we don't have that
because we have to have more trust and
faith
yeah that our brother man is not going
to betray us
our sister's not going to betray us
yeah trust the process that's it man
you can see now how at this century
people are becoming better people now
there's still we got some
we still got some time for some guys
they're still around they don't really
they didn't they didn't mend into
society well but
people are becoming better now they're
becoming smarter
you know yeah they're looking at look
they're questioning christmas they're
questioning the holidays
anybody yeah question they're
questioning god
why is he a man you know we're
questioning everything now
yeah things that we look at how dare you
question this but they got to go on
their own journey and pass and find out
yeah yeah that's the interesting part
that you know everyone has to find it in
their own time
the waking up exactly it's all in their
own time
and then when you we made that statement
about living in the moment there's no
there's nothing feeling like living in
the moment because living in the moment
it's hard to grasp that feeling yeah how
difficult we can't even do it now
yeah how hard is it to live in that
moment think about how hard we're right
here yeah when you live in that moment
it's so sensational then huh
when it's gone you [ __ ] what's going on
that moment is can't hold it yeah
yeah he can't hold it you can't hold it
that [ __ ] moment
and then you think the whole thing how
to get back trying to get that feeling
again
but it's not something that you can get
back you got to summon it it comes when
you don't even prepare
but it gave you a feeling that one tenth
of a second
oh i can't even explain that to somebody
what that is well that's like getting
back to the breathing man
that's why your breathing is so
important being tuned into your breath
and breathing in and out through your
nose
because that brings you into the moment
that's like i'm some people like human
beings
when they really get in tune with
themselves they get in trouble
because they can't handle that power
it's a lot of power
yeah they can't handle it that's a lot
of power
you know it is yeah it's very powerful
[Music]
yeah when it all but it's all opened up
whoa
whoa he said i don't want this stuff no
no you get
got that five minutes
what they look like is this a girl a guy
what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's insane
that is insane god life is uh
listen um i look at everything
i look at women look at people look at
people who are looked at as
and everything if they were they were
teachers those guys were our teachers
and that's what this big world is a
school it's where we live it's one big
school
i like it and all of all about all of
our encounters are classes
imagine how much how many classes we
endure in his life if you're in the
moment
yeah if you're able to just be in the
moment
you know and really be in those
exchanges with people
are you able to grasp grasp the lessons
that moment's a [ __ ] the fools
guys
were true well we've been
i think in western culture we've been
programmed to be
to live in our fantasies and to live an
hour
that's what i do i'm all in my think
about
constantly we're constantly trained to
live in our fantasies and live in our
own little
dreams and never actually do anything
with those we're not meant to they don't
want us to
they they don't but there is they don't
want us to be
the full expression of ourselves
well a lot of times we don't want to be
the fool well we don't want to expose
the food we're afraid of
ourselves we're afraid we're afraid of
who we are yeah
we're afraid of because we think we know
who we are we don't want other people to
know what that part of us
you know what you mean yeah holy [ __ ]
yeah that's why we climb mountains dude
what happens when you listen i always
think when i die and i
and that's when i begin to live i wake
up and i'm around everybody and they saw
me
do everything i did in private like i
would like if i died i wake up and i'm
around there's all these people
and i don't know if i know their name
but they saw me do everything
that i hated when i was in private
jerking on [ __ ] my
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] that this time i
shoulda did been with somebody i
shouldn't have been where he's doing all
this stuff i'm hiding i think no one
knows to this moment and
i wake up after dying and all these
people saw me do everything i thought i
hit from everyone
how would that feel i would be in
between i'd be ashamed i would say sorry
in my life i would say this and then
make it liberated though a little bit
yeah well
everybody knows so there you go you know
what that's what happened to the toe
that's why i felt liberal i had that
humiliating feeling that it liberated
yeah yeah you know the only one that
really matters is you because you know
it all you've seen it all you've been in
there
the whole time you know everything that
happened
absolutely so then like what is someone
else's
opinion of that even matter no it's
because their opinion
believe it or not is my opinion of
myself
everybody else's opinions is opinion
that you conjured up already
you had that opinion about that stuff
before that even came out their mouth
and that's why and that's why that
happened because you have to face those
opinions you have to face your self-hate
your self-doubt
your self-alignment you know your
self-illusion
yeah you know imagine after all the
stuff
you know who we think we are who we
believe we are and then
the older we get the sicker we get god
is saying come on tell me who you are
keep telling me who you are and then you
say to yourself
you like even though we get at this
stage of our life we start to become
more spiritual and think to god then you
say to yourself
all the stuff i got and you say wow i'm
still not doing enough for god i'm not
praying enough i'm like
servant enough you know you always that
happens you know because you know
you've seen um people before you seen
your family you seen them get old you
saw them strong at one time you saw them
living their life you saw them get old
you saw them get weak you saw them get
feeble you saw them die
and now my process is going to how am i
going to do this with dignity am i going
to be addicted about this
how am i going to handle this about
dying
yeah we're aging okay sorry
you know some people do with dignity
some people do it with
harshness they [ __ ] this and get uh m16
and start taking out other people too
because
living it feels complicated it's even
more complicated than dying
dying is easy living is [ __ ] up for
rent
you know yeah into suffering
yeah sometime
yeah yeah but we keep living because we
think we're gonna get the message
even since the biblical times we still
listen for the message
you know we acknowledge that always we
seek knowledge to with the grave we
think it we stay around because
we think we even if we believe in the
second coming we're gonna see
something's gonna give us a message
see i think yeah you feel me i don't
know yeah
about that second coming is kind of we i
don't know what religion it is but
something about we're still waiting for
that
we're still waiting for that even though
we might be scientifically
aware that this can't be true but we're
still uh feeling our barometer wait for
it
our being wait for it has nothing to do
with knowledge
it's who we are being as a whole
barometer
we could be idiots but we know it's
coming
you know we'll be waiting for it
you know we could be idiots our brains
could be this big but still we have to
feel we know
something greater than us yeah you know
idiots we have nothing
whatever they call retards whatever you
are but we still made it into something
greater than us yeah
so that makes them smarter than most of
the guys that have education that
believe they're greater than everything
whoo guys god humbles
the universe whatever we call how it
humbles us
what's your sense of god joby
spirituality actually i grew up in kind
of a strict
sort of private church but my parents
were not
too hard on me and my brother in that
way they didn't really
hammer us and they got out of that and
so we had some structure there that was
interesting where i
got to read the bible all the way
through and do and know quite a lot
of all the stories and the things that
really mattered so i appreciated it for
that
there were some good people in it too
but
the way i would say it is that the
mountains are my church
and that's where i go to pray
and i do a lot of praying when i'm there
because i need a lot of help
usually you listen the mountains talk to
you
they do the woods the forest they talk
to you i know people think i'm crazy but
man
absolutely
um well there's vibrations all around us
i mean everything is vibrations
and are there is no sound
until the vibrations hit our eardrums
and then it transfers a signal into our
brain that creates a sense yes
it tells us when to be this we end up
we're in the forwards we're in the
truth it tells you when to be afraid hey
be careful yes
exactly and then eventually you saw
those lines right
you don't even see it but it turns out
something's not right here
exactly cool oh yeah so the lines pop up
right yeah yeah definitely that's
happened to me plenty of times
i remember one time being in pakistan
yeah or something like that the
avalanche little avalanche was coming
down and i was like
maybe and a guy came down
he said we're out of here i said oh i
thought so he goes what were you waiting
for
i was like well i was thinking about it
and it felt like i should go down he
goes
never ever ever go against that feeling
the first one when you go something's
wrong get the [ __ ] out yeah
immediately because it's right that
you're feeling it for a reason maybe
think about it
still go with your first feeling
whatever is the first one is probably
right
definitely it's been that i took that
it's your instincts
it's an instinct that right so much
older than you it's probably older than
god
the prophet it's the original advice
yeah yeah yeah exactly
dude it's the original advice get the
[ __ ] out of here get out of here
we gotta go right now i feel that way
for a reason yeah oh dude i love that
well you know that's that's also
you know the way our lives are set up
now people just are so out of touch with
that
those senses you know yeah well people
live in the cities
right right so you get used to you know
that kind of lifestyle
but i've always enjoyed being in the far
places i think that was part of the
reason i got into climbing because i
wanted to
test myself and endure pain stay out in
a tent for two months on the glacier go
to the high altitudes come
back suffering just hammer myself
and then you find out what you really
are go on a mountain by yourself
completely alone stuff like that i
climbed the south or the north face of
everest
in one day on all by myself i was the
only person on the mountain i went in
before anybody was there
and just did it and it was like came
down did that
that was the greatest experience of my
life because i knew who i was after that
did you know what you were up against
yeah i did
by that time i was i had gotten a pretty
big time experience where i'm like i
know what it's going to take to do this
and i was a professional element of math
during yourself with yourself by
yourself
yeah that's the reason that we have
that's the reason that we have mates and
get married because we can't live by us
with ourselves not by ourselves but with
ourselves yeah people say we can't live
alone no we can't live with ourselves
yeah that's why have you ever heard
well mike you know people go on these uh
i'm interested in doing this at some
point but you go on like a 10-day
silent retreat no talking
for 10 days and people come back and say
they were literally going insane
absolutely that's what alexander the
great father told him he said
learn to trust nobody and be alone
learn to be a
him to be able to live alone that's what
he said live with them able to live
alone
you know that's true
because none of us never experienced it
or we experienced it for such a short
time
hey we don't want to do this no more
most of us never experienced just
being with ourselves and our thoughts
and our past
and that stuff comes up but we've been
assaulted i went bad stuff we saw
happened to our mother whoa we don't
want to deal with it hey let me
look put on together look at the cartoon
let's just get away from those we
thought
we had from the past yeah you know we
have to sometimes um
embrace who we are this is who we are
what the [ __ ] and i can't help but it's
the way the universe made us you're not
all the same that's why
this is a special place because we're
not all the same
every insect every bug has a different
print every line every tiger has
different stripes
spots yeah i mean billions of animals
and bugs and stuff and they're all
different
they have identification everything's
about life is about identification
a number a print who's this guy
what bloodline he comes from
even from insects bugs everything
you know
it's yeah stuff
what's going on here oh i love that well
you're on tape man there's no secrets
okay
yeah why are you whispering
[Music]
tell us about the yeti oh my god you saw
yeti
i saw yeti come on oh [ __ ]
all right check this out you can't make
this up so here's the deal so
i was when i told you that story about
climbing that mountain eight hours i
came down
and then we had to the base camp so
there were
some other people were still coming down
so i had to wait so my friend from spain
had some friends with him like 12 people
and he so he
he had some people checking in and they
were all there and i knew some of those
people so i had dinner with them that
night in their tent
they invited me so towards the end of
the night
everybody starts to leave go to their
own tent and we head to dinner
everything's finished
and all of a sudden i'm sitting in the
corner of the tent there's like five of
us in the tent
something grabbed the corner of the tent
and started shaking it
like this and then did it again
and we're thinking it's some friend of
ours from another camp [ __ ] around
[ __ ] around
and after a while we think somebody's
gonna walk in nobody walks in so we get
up and
like what the [ __ ] was going on with
that we walk out
as i'm the last guy to get out of the
tent so i open the tent and i noticed
everybody standing there looking this
way just like
this just not moving at all like looking
at something
and it was a full moon so it's really
bright outside
and it and we were on a glacier so it
kind of reflected i mean it was very
bright it's like almost
daylight and i look over and right there
to the left about 15 feet away from me
is this coiled up crouched down
black looked like the yeti's not black
get out right here
it's black dude it's [ __ ] black
everybody loves
this white thing you know no no no and a
friend of mine had seen one
before in the same area and told me what
it looked like he said it moves real
fast and it's all black i'm like
okay i didn't expect to see one i just
heard the story but when i saw it it was
exactly what he said how big was it
it was massive the crazy crowd still
crouched down it had kind of
like a nose of like more of like a
longer like a dog but it
it was this jet black really shiny long
hair
it had yellow eyes that really you could
reflect in the sunset it looked at us
for a while
and then it just jumped and it jumped
over a pile of rocks that was probably
not a bear
no no no at first i thought is that a
dog i'm like man that thing's huge
and then i thought it was a yak because
the yaks were coming in to pick our
equipment um
i thought it's like a big cow with and i
thought that's not a yak
and then it just kept sitting there
looking at us and then it just took off
like in
some supernatural flight over a hundred
foot pile of rocks
but the crazy thing was instinctively i
actually started moving towards it like
i want to
go up there and look and there was a kid
who worked for me a nepalese kid he put
his hand right here on my stomach
he was standing there watching the whole
thing too he worked in the kitchen and
he said don't go up there
and i was like did everybody just see
what i saw
and everybody's like yeah holy [ __ ]
okay and when i saw it i was just kind
of like oh okay
well that's a real animal that exists
and seems to have
never natural quality that i never saw
before that's kind of elusive or
something
but then after a couple days we were
waiting to get picked up by the yaks
and i started taking all the food out of
my tent because i'm thinking man why did
it
why did it shake the corner i was it was
like what did it want
and i was kind of glad to get out of
there i was afraid it seemed like
something that would just destroy you
do you take any psychedelics
mushrooms like that no no no i like to
smoke some marijuana but that's it
i think it's pretty sick that's what
everybody else is they said what are you
taking up on the mountain i'm like on
the mountain i take
my toothbrush that's about it it's got a
light weight going up there that's a
good break off
from all the party time but uh
yeah no that's i bet it's pretty
psychedelic though man
what it is that's yeah it's
like you're going to other planets yeah
you know like you're in a different
place it's so unique and so special
it's so high up there and your existence
is
just a big deal every day like there's a
place in india the island off
outside of india that the people from
they've been there from africa for 60
000 years
really yeah they had they had no contact
with human beings if you
contact with them they start dying
because we affect them
they've never been inoculated and stuff
so they start dying so i've seen them on
filming for people people have been
killed by them they've killed some um
visitors that try to come on that island
and try to they kill some um
that's off the coast of india right yeah
they killed the people from the
missionary they killed
the mission people trying to change them
to christians and killed them this guy
was documenting this whole thing how he
was going to bring christianity to these
people
you know they're really small he didn't
make it onto the shore before they
speared him and drugged him and they hit
him
that's a rough one yeah [ __ ] that
mike thinks we should civilize everyone
but i think i don't think so i
think that we should understand every
species of human being and who they are
and where they are
yeah and how how do they relate to us
i'm interested in that
yeah but can you go
safely take a look and no i just want to
know what they believe
is important what do they think is
important do they believe food's in
front what do they hold sacred
what do they believe that god's given
them to make them special
because we all believe that god has
given us something to make us special
black people believe god has given us
rhythm style class to make us different
from any other people and stuff
and every other people probably say he
gave us this he gave us brains and
telling us this because we do this
and he gave us this and we all try to
put that in together where did that come
from
did it stem from this where did that
thought where did the idea come from
of us being one or somebody being
superior to my being inferior where does
thought come from
who created those thoughts who created
the thought of god
it's just in us yeah it's no this is
what i found i think we get it from
animals
that um we're born to worship
i think that's what happened i think
even the handicapped
people were born since the beginning of
time like
idiots you know not the form that they
even worshipped i agree yeah you know
so you get a guy from harvard that
starts going in the signs and say
there's no god but then you have an
idiot the guy the first person that was
born
four or five thousand million years ago
he worshipped something
and you're going to tell me this guy's a
educated guy now he knows more than this
person
that's born five million years before
him
now you would say he is more advanced
but you think this guy knows more than
the guy that's born five million years
before him
maybe not can you believe what that guy
seen five million years before him this
guy who could never dream of singing
could never see him papers or books
yeah yeah because they have never seen
it to write it down
yeah well mike you said it uh
i don't know what we were doing maybe we
were just in here recording an ad but
then we started talking afterwards and
you said
it's natural it's a natural instinct
for an individual or a creature
to ask for help and then joby you said
when you're up on the mountain you're
doing a lot of praying and i'm sure
you're
asking for a lot of assistance from
nature and the universe to
bring in whatever circumstances would be
preferable
so maybe that's it mike like what you
were saying it's just a natural instinct
you know even if you're alone to ask for
help
yeah yeah i was just thinking of doing
you said that's what the actual
every person every answer everybody was
a message asking for help just walking
too long needs water
yeah oh god or we call whatever that
whoever created that word
god that's what the person said oh this
oh god oh this help me please
i don't care that i've said that all my
life yeah
i said that when i was in the stages of
not believing i said that
yeah yeah you know
yeah [ __ ] dude
that's how come we know we have god i
don't care all the non-believers all the
atheists
when it's the last moment of our life we
say oh god please help us
or whatever we call god oh god please
help us or whatever we know that's
bigger than us we say please help us
even we don't believe please help us the
moon the sky
the birds help us
joby it's a real pleasure having you
here
big time thank you man i really
appreciate you
good luck god bless you you're the man
you're a [ __ ] inspiration
seriously well it's been a pleasure to
be here
i got to meet somebody i was
you know your hero mike for sure
you're really awesome you come back man
you come back from stuff i'm kind of
coming back now too
you know that's why i figured i would
get some
it would be nice to meet you today and
visit about these things i figured you'd
give me some advice hey you know listen
to what i've
my experience i found out that um
did you the god do you it tests you
he tests you and see how how much do
this you can take before you say let's
just
just be finished with this you know i
mean he wants to show you something you
want to see how much you can take how
much you can handle
life you say you love life you want to
live life i'ma show you life
life is beautiful but you have to accept
the good and the bad as being beautiful
you can't can't accept the girl
distributing we lose somebody our life
sucks life is beautiful because life
gave us the ability to
just know them on our journey in life we
met them
we loved them we care about they care
about us
that's that's the purpose of life just
enjoy what we have while we journey
through it
yeah my pleasure brother
i needed it we all do
because sometimes we don't understand
like what is this thing what is my
purpose why am i here
why do i have to go through this pain
well i have to go to this field all the
time
why can't it just be peaceful all the
time then there wouldn't be life
you know it wouldn't be life we have to
we have to take life at its term life on
lifetime not
our life on our terms you know we have
to live life
on life terms not on our terms
i'm really happy to be here with you you
have so much courage
thank you very much
yeah thanks man amazing
thank you mike
joby thank you again thank you brother
yeah brother
absolutely you come back you're gonna
come back it'll be good it'll be good
mike amazing episode yeah you know one
of my favorites
i keep thinking you know every time i
think i make a mistake but i keep
thinking um
it's all about love love is the essence
of life i keep believing that
but i'm battling it with it they can
come on i can't can't believe it
you can't be that yeah come on [ __ ] they
came is it that simple
yeah is it that simple i think so yeah
we're fighting for something that's just
so it's right there you can do it but
you just don't want to let go
yeah it's like no my [ __ ] afraid to be
happy you're afraid to you know
the enjoy could listen when you really
find real love and stuff my first
experience with real love
the first you know i've never
experienced i ran the other way
there's no way that you're going to
accept it for all the scary
the things that somebody really loves
you regardless of all your flaws and
everything
and you feel like you're a disgusting
piece of [ __ ] and somebody says i love
you though
you might want to kill that person how
could you i hate me how do you love me
you know love is scary
because it's so beautiful yeah
well yeah on that note how do we watch
his show
who do you think yeah we're gonna well
you got a lot of great youtube videos
yeah let's check those out is there any
where people can follow you
and follow are you on instagram are you
on social media
uh-huh yeah i'm all over facebook and
instagram so people can follow me from
there my
jobyogwin yep j.o.b
he's just such a humble man he's so
lovable and stuff doing the stuff that's
definitely
i would be so scared my ego would get
involved
cause i'm so afraid yeah i mean yeah
i know i know he's amazing this guy
i love him thanks man thank you um
well hey everybody thank you so much for
listening to this really special episode
this is a beautiful episode absolutely
beautiful thank you brother thank you
mike thank you thank you for the
platform thank you for the opportunity
hey everybody check out our website
hotboxandpodcast.com you can find all
our episodes there as well as
listen on podcast one
until next time i'm evan britton i'm
mike tyson you know i always see
guys like joby they're always great guys
that you're so humble and stuff yeah
they do just
incredible things and know what
greatness is the definition of greatness
is doing the most difficult thing to use
with the
you know difficult thing in order with
the simplest of these
and that's what you're doing you're
breaking wrecking running the mountains
take people's days he's doing it in
hours
can you imagine it takes me a couple of
days ago but i'm gonna do it in a few
hours
come on man what are you doing making a
nap yeah
they're lazy yeah exactly you need uh
what's that diet you you need
what's the diet thing again you need
don't eat dirt debbie donuts man
or something god how did you do it in
eight hours god
that was really fit back in those days
[ __ ] dude you're still
fit bro fit enough i hope all right
y'all
until next time we're out of here out of
here guys
hey joe man joe but like what's that
come from the bible job when you put
joby to it
yeah it was my great grandfather's name
joey joey
[Music]
you